and if any of you had ever wondered what
kind of new world Blizzard would create
well like 17 years is too long to wait
and my friends the wait ends right now
one shot one kill Eric take my friends
it's already kicking off as the hype is
real this is crazy we just came from
downstairs where they have the big
opening press conference ceremony thing
and they release they show overwatch oh
they're like hey check out the CG
trainer oh hey by the way here's
gameplay oh hey why don't hey you can go
play it immediately if you want to so we
did we ran upstairs went into we were
lucky enough to have a sort of a special
media press
go in and players we went in we paid
three rounds and there this is us
dumping all of that information on you
folks so overwatch what is it it's a
multiplayer shooter first of its kind
for Blizzard because they've never
entered the genre kind of like I guess
tfp team fortress like I guess a little
bit I thought it was I was really hyped
on I saw it on downstairs I was in to
see have played her intricate was and it
turns out super inch good so there's an
insulting team and is the defending team
sort of Allah team for chazwy pay two
modes one was kind of like the payload
stuff in tf2 where you're like Carl
you're like patrol to keeping a car's
pushing it through a level and the other
one was like what some of the new call
of duty hard point Mike hard point so
it's like point by point yeah but you
were straight up a defending team or an
exciting to you and all the characters
are there not faction based you can pick
from any of the set of characters for
both teams under students like four
different like ropes or ranches yeah
what is it was like a halt support tank
and defender yeah so each one has like
you know different characters obviously
the defenders are obviously better at
like they drop turrets and they like
better like when you're playing defense
i guess i never we don't try wandering
assault i think it'd be a little weird
maybe during the payload I don't know um
and yeah I mean like there's there's so
many variants but assault class you've
played a bunch you played like Reaper
yeah it's not all this diaper at the
tanks were kind of the big lumbering big
ones yeah big characters and then I
guess the
what was the support and matters of
whether to give shields they can also
drop turrets and the special abilities
are pretty crazy like condos like you
freakin shoot out like a twin dragon
that goes through walls apparently eight
so like it should be mentioned it like
kind of like team fortress two do all
the weapons abilities are set to the
character but there's not that many like
you're gonna top this everyone has a
different one so there's like it could
be a grappling hook or a speed thing or
like you're able to like Darth through
the air or teleport and then everyone
has a kind of the and special ability on
e that I was like a little bit of cool
down and then everyone's an ult as well
but takes a longer to charge yeah yeah
it's like in the middle of the dial
you'll see that it's like oh it's ready
because it's like starts to pulse it
unleashes like a pretty strong attack
doesn't see my tooth too crazy even
though like condos looks really cool
like I don't think it's like 20 p or
anything like that um and not charges up
with time and with kill as well yeah
when I was getting kills it was just
going to yep your back yep your back so
first round who did you go I picked
hands oh he's interesting heat his run
is like a grappling hook he can also
climb walls and then he just has like
charging like he's like he shoots arrows
he charges it and then you let it go he
has a scattershot that's interesting
it's like when you see someone you don't
want to aim it directly Adam you want to
aim it at a cheap because it splits into
like six arrows and you're like bounces
all over the place things also like a
good mechanic board like you know
there's the tank guy that has a shield
right yes he's in front of you so you
kind of want to like shoot it off to the
side or something so it bounces it hits
him from the back or something like that
yeah I played his tracer who are you
were saying when we watched the
conference you're like our choices ok
and I was like you can't say I cactus
okie from watching a trainer that's
ridiculous Chase is ok i think i got
like it i think i got 15 for one or two
yeah i mean there's a snob score right
yeah i was tired top i was MVP i'm at
the end of the match it says who the MVP
is and instead of showing like the last
kill it shows like the best flurry from
the MVP in the round yeah which is cool
and also what I found when I played that
first level of payload is that the wrens
actually eat whether you manage to like
shot at the attacking team were you one
of yourself they were pretty fast like
they were like maybe five to ten minutes
each 5-10 minutes definitely I think we
steamrolled one game which is third game
second game maybe that's a second a
second game we defended them really
easily ok and then
third game we won it in like three
minutes three minutes maybe a bad one
behind the camera and I was I was I was
all you baby sick way tracer though
she's got those deal weapons she has
this sort of when he hit shift it like
almost like blink suit for words mm-hmm
and then if you had e it like teleports
you back or vs climb back which is great
because she has this it's like a big
bomb so you just got this a bunch of
dudes our age but boom boom boom drop
the bomb and then hit and you're like
deuces kind of thing goes up I'm second
game at well three of us r in who did I
played Reinhart he is one of the tank
he's pretty he's pretty fun like he can
drop down the shield it protects like
you and your teammates it's pretty wide
um and then because his like shift or
like a run room is pretty crazy it's a
freaking charge so like this juggernaut
stategy line although it's like boom
boom and it's like am smash and you know
dead he also has like a like a range
type ability he just swings he shoots
like kind of like a fire strike in front
of him and he's all take a like-kind of
like a earthquake smash like in front of
you does a lot of damage if they're in
front of you I tried it like I rain it
didn't do anything I got it creeped on
the plug oh no one's there oh yeah he's
he's a lot of fun um forgot who you
played in the sack I've had like a
sniper it's like a Russian lady we'll
put the name on the screen now and some
sort of game thing and yeah she was
great so she has a instead of having any
run abilities she has like a straight up
to wake to grappling hooks in situation
where she can like wrap on it it's got a
decent range maybe about 30 feet or so
and it's got a cool down every 10
seconds less you have to be real careful
with it she can't jump very far if you
find the place you have to have like
real intent to get there and this is
also the part where you brought up a
concern about the fact that there's kind
of is no run button then because
everyone has this like seed thing like
either a teleporter her grapple because
we were so pushed up ahead I was like
right like walking and then like
grappling a little bit and then walking
it took me like a good while to get back
in what the head like if you play
counter-strike and you used to getting
headshots and you play as her I was like
old band dead dead dead even the big
guys just like killing them up so I got
another like 12 killstreak I think
enough before somebody got me and but
cheesy you're able to get out of Dodge
with her please day as well antic laters
like some dhalsim looking dude yeah like
a monk I he's got the Indian [ __ ] days
he floats through that but it's like a
support character I saw he was healing
me a bunch of when I wanna hang balls at
me you're like you're throwing balls
yeah but whatever he was throwing it was
healing me and I was just standing on
the front line is like this relay combo
like I'm sure your rainy from above
while mean and you're just like sitting
on the front line because that was a
game like we let like literally kept
them in the spawn and like you're not
coming forward and then in game three
against the same folks we kind of this
was a quick one we didn't at three
minutes and I play this Reaper who is
the next year everyone who's cosplaying
as Reaper is hell it's like this dude
he's got like dual shotguns they are
insanely powerful I didn't realize if
you get anywhere close to somebody and
you like knock them off it's a it's
really powerful his abilities were he
could like basically teleport into line
of sight pretty much anywhere and
there's a little bit of a cool down and
the people can see where you pop ups you
have to become a careful with it okay
and his run thing turned him into a sort
of a rape character where he was on
vulnerable you get a little bit of a
speed boost so apparently what the great
thing to do is to teleport in Lund your
ult which is if you hit Q we basically
kills anyone who's niram so it happened
in the trailer then used out rape
ability just to get I'm out of here for
anyone who's left over and who did you
plan I played as a support I forget her
name her like one of our abilities that
she can drop turrets like she drop a
bunch of em and they all just shoot you
I heard some guy next to me like how do
i get rid of the turret it's like I
literally had like five surrounding a
tank and he's trying to hold the shield
but there's like all shooting him a
difference not her ultimate is if you
can set it up it's she dropped a
teleporter and then you can drop a
teleporter back like at home base if
you're there I think and then you can
just like you and your teammates and
just get to the point movie like faster
so I don't like the engineer in ds2 like
setting those things up and but you have
to be careful because the IT team can
destroy them I died oh hey and Andy
played as a farah yeah yeah whoo MVP and
if happened behind the camera yeah
apparently was telling us he could shoot
you straight up just fly outside the map
and just go whom I gotta kill and then
John
lay waste to the human rocket launcher
penalty just like rain Rockets down or
halt I think just drops I think you see
in the trailer or all just drops like a
lot of like bombs or rockets like just
coming out of her shoulders on but it's
it's a blast it's fun I mean we've only
played 34 games and we're like let's get
back out there but we got to do this you
know yeah first impressions right at the
gate I don't know we have to play a bit
of warhead what do you think about it I
think it's a lot of fun i think it's
it's interesting it's new it's a
slightly different for blizzard I think
movements a little weird for me because
I've come from playing ecology so I'm
just like what are you talking to play
tracer because she can kind of do that
kind of stuff I used to go show um
that's my only like slight concern is
just like the movement and maybe this
there's only a couple skills you know
like I don't know maybe are they gonna
build upon that or is that enough I
don't know what about you and so I was
really into hyped about it I was
thinking this will be the one blazer
game that I really get into I think like
in the past couple years and really
reminding me two porches to the one
thing that stood out to me was i have i
don't think i've ever played a
first-person game with that many classes
with that many systems and that many
like different characters that you learn
that stuff so quickly you hit f1 it
gives you an overland says these are
like the three things you need to know
that this character can do get q hit ian
hit shift and then just go have fun I've
never played like that's what Blizzard
do they take complicated systems they
did it with Warcraft they did or what
hearthstone it kind of did it with
starcraft 2 is well eventually with the
toils of where they teach people how to
play systems that are really do the
intricate wheelie quickly i will I felt
comfortable with all of the characters
they paid within a minute and I think
this game I don't know you try not to
like get we're in the moment at the
moment try not to get spun up about us
but that King was great yeah that was
good fun so we're gonna go play some
more of us there's continuing coverage
of blizzcon of course on gamespot com
but the next couple of days keep it here
and we'll have more impressions I will
watch as the day continues but we're
gonna play now
awesome
you